[Music]
24 hours after the city came together to
celebrate they returned to remember
[Music]
now we will read the names of the five
beautiful souls that were lost yesterday
wilhelm
hospital
virginia sorensen
lyanna owen
this time the authorities were taking no
chances using trucks to block the roads
as thousands gathered for a candlelit
vigil
the chief of police among those paying
their respects
how is waukesha feeling tonight
right now our morning
right and we're going to move forward in
the future and heal this is a very
resilient community and i'm very proud
and honored to be
a member and part of this community
overwhelmed mystified
horrified
and
wondering
how could it happen and now how do we
move forward
this event
shows what waukesha really stands for
and and how the how the people care for
each other
on sunday night the first sign of
trouble was the screams
as a large car tore through the crowd of
families hitting adults and children
again
and again
and again i heard and saw
the people being hit but what you could
do more than seeing is hearing and just
that sound was
insane
those injured including toddlers and
three sets of siblings
neil stolzmark has run the karate studio
here for 40 years
everyone was just crying and screaming
and
i ran out to try to help the
victims
one man 39 year old daryl brooks is in
custody his criminal record stretches
back decades
police want to charge him with five
counts of first-degree intentional
homicide when he appears in court later
today
there are few signs now of the horror
that happened on this street beyond some
police markings on the ground and yet
the pain
the confusion the shock is everywhere in
this small commuter town everyone in
walk ashore seems to know someone who's
been affected
the theme of this year's parade was
comfort and joy
but in the last 24 hours this town has
witnessed trauma and tragedy that it
will never forget
joe pike sky news waukesha wisconsin